[Music]
adele says her fans definitely didn't go
easy on her after making a last-minute
decision to cancel her las vegas
residency it was horrible and it was it
was the the reaction was
brutal
brutal
i was a shell of a person for a couple
of months
now the singer is explaining to bbc
radio 4 why she still thinks she made
the right choice i definitely felt
everyone's disappointment
and i was devastated
and i was frightened
about you know letting them down and i
thought i could pull it together and
make it work and i couldn't and i stand
by that decision
adele opened up about the backlash she
received back in january after she made
the tearful announcement that she was
postponing her vegas shows i'm so sorry
but um
[Music]
my show ain't ready
we've tried absolutely everything that
we can
to put it together in time
and for it to be good enough for you
it's been impossible to finish the show
and
i can't give you what i have right now
um
and i'm gutted i'm gutted and i'm sorry
it's the last minute
in the end adele says she doesn't regret
calling it off not even for a big payday
or the risk of losing a lot of money you
can't buy me you can't buy me for
nothing i'm not gonna just do a show
because
i have to or because people can be let
down or because you know we're gonna
lose loads of money like i'm like the
show's not good enough and we think
adele rarely disappoints in concert
absolutely
despite the criticism the 34 year old
singer admits it all comes down to
putting on the best show for her fans of
course i could be someone on tik tok or
instagram live every day being like i'm
working on it like of course i'm working
on it of course i'm working i'm not
gonna update you if i ain't got nothing
to update you with like you know because
that just leads to more disappointment
so it makes sense why the grammy winner
has kept relatively quiet since the
initial postponement no one wants a
repeat of this i'm really embarrassed
and i'm
so sorry to everyone that's travelled
again
i'm really really sorry i'm really sorry
um we're on it we're gonna reschedule
all of the dates it's still unknown when
adele will make her return to sin city
but fans were thrilled to see her back
on stage at london's hyde park
[Music]
and it was an emotional return for the
hello hit maker to say the
[Music]
i least once happy to be here
[Applause]
[Music]